вважаю, що володіння зброєю та суворі закони про зброю
не поєднуються. Приїжджай до Німеччини, де
громадяни озброєні, але не настільки
небезпечні. Ми всі знаємо ситуацію
в моїй рідній країні, у старих добрих США,
ми озброєні до
зубів  за оцінками, 101 одиниця зброї на кожні 100
громадян, це більше зброї, ніж людей,
і це, безперечно, найвищий показник у світі,
але Німеччина також має зброю, вона
посідає друге місце в ЄС і навіть
четверте місце у світі за кількістю зброї на людину.
зброя — це суперзірки,
я маю на увазі, що Голлівуд рекламує зброю в кожному
кримінальному телевізійному шоу це міжнародне це
стосується німців це стосується
американців познайомтеся з Юргісом Прабхою, винахідником
божевільної зброї своїми руками та одним
із 2,3 мільйонів зареєстрованих власників зброї в Німеччині,
ви повинні розуміти, що зброя — це
це дуже велика частина нашої культури, і
це також дуже в центрі уваги
соціального життя багатьох невеликих міст,
збройний клуб є місцем зустрічі номер один
у всьому місті, кожен
є членом т  протягом місяця збройового клубу
він показав мені шафки, де він зберігає
свої 34 зброї, коли вони не використовуються. Одним
із важливих стовпів німецького
законодавства про зброю є те, що зброя не призначена для
самозахисту. Не можна
захищатися за допомогою  зброя Уряд Німеччини
каже, що це наша робота, ми захищаємо вас
поліцейськими все, щоб вони не хотіли, щоб
цивільні особи використовували зброю для самозахисту,
що не так у США.  Майже
дві третини американських власників зброї кажуть, що
вони придбали свою зброю для
самозахисту, і ось результати
в США.  понад 60% вбивств
пов’язано зі зброєю в Німеччині це менше
10% нещодавно в середньому було 92
смерті від вогнепальної зброї на день у Сполучених Штатах
у Німеччині трохи більше двох, то
що тут відбувається, як Німеччина може
мати так багато зброї, але так  набагато менше
законів про насильство з використанням зброї в США.  Обмеження на зброю є
одними
з найслабших у світі, і часто
вони зовсім відсутні
в 36 з 50 штатів. У Техасі
немає реєстрації, ліцензії та дозволу,
щоб купити зброю, ви
навіть можете придбати вогнепальну зброю, не виходячи з
машини, тож як  Ви купуєте зброю в Німеччині,
так що це забирає багато часу, тож вам
доведеться витратити майже рік на
підготовку та взяти участь у збройовому клубі,
відпрацьовувати їхній невеликий іспит, вам
видадуть ліцензію без судимості,
щоб бути повнолітнім, ви не можете  просто зайдіть у
магазин і купіть один, і є ще одна
велика різниця між Німеччиною та
США: Німеччина вживає заходів
після масових розстрілів у 2002 році. 19-
річний підліток зайшов у свою колишню середню школу
в центральній Німеччині та вбив 16
людей напів-  автоматичний пістолет, потім у
2009 році інша школа, стріляючи в підлітка,
вбила 15 людей і поранила ще дев’ятьох
, перш ніж покінчити з собою,
але після цих трагедій контроль над зброєю
було посилено, Німеччина стала
єдиною державою  Ніколи у світі не намагаються вимагати
психіатричне обстеження для будь-кого
віком до 25 років, перш ніж купувати зброю, з
такою кількістю правил і норм, що ви можете
подумати, що німці набридли, але насправді
більшість підтримує закони своїх націй, я
думаю, що це хороший компроміс.
прийнято більшістю людей,
хоча у нас все ще ведуться дебати, вони все
ще люди, які хочуть видалення органів,
і ще є люди, які
хочуть повної свободи, ви знаєте, для
всіх, як американська система, тому
все ще дискусії, але я думаю, що
більшість людей досить  задоволені
системою згідно з численними опитуваннями,
переважна більшість американців кажуть, що
хочуть елементарного контролю над зброєю, але республіканці
та Національна стрілецька асоціація кажуть,
що це неможливо. Здається,
у Німеччині вона працює досить добре, тож хто
правий